have you heard of I think it's called a
five intelligence or some [ __ ] like that
there's like so like so for example like
it's it's like the saying where it's
like if you judge a fish by how fast it
could climb a tree then you're you're
the [ __ ] or whatever you have that or
it's like of course the monkeys gonna
win right yeah so like but if you judge
a fish on how fast it could swim it's
gonna beat the monkey yeah so it's like
everyone has their kind of niche right
so like that is like spatial
intelligence some people are good with
that or like some people are emotionally
intelligent or socially intelligent or
like whatever and then there's a whole
list of it but mmm it might be that like
you don't spend time doing puzzles and
like you know building so you're just
new at it you know it's not like your
dumb ass it sucks because that's that's
that's the skill that I really want
because I will love naked and afraid oh
yeah I watch that show I realized how
much I wouldn't survive there's so much
like I think it's like a human innate
like there's such a weird attraction to
just building yeah it's like [ __ ] dude I
could watch it build all day cuz they're
even in that show you start to realize
who really has a knack and a skill for
something yeah so there's like episodes
where you see people in a similar
environment but it's a different episode
but you see people build these things
like I saw this guy he built his wrath
it was the shittiest looking thing I've
ever seen in my life
it was just like straw and that's the
that's the rap that I would create but
there was another person another guy was
creating a wrath yeah and it looked like
something you could buy off a catalog
like it was so crazy like he built a
chair on the wrath yeah and then a
runner that you could like steer in it
and I'm like how the [ __ ] did you make
that from these trees in like two weeks
that makes no sense
like I would add the other guy I kid you
not defend his you want his wrath was it
was two logs that were strung together
by mine and he just laid on it literally
created a raft with eight armchair damn
well I bet you people say that [ __ ]
about your cooking
oh maybe right so it's like if you were
in May
fraid you'll be the guy that like I'll
catch the meerkat and you cook the meal
I definitely need somebody to help me
get to that point yeah cuz I look at
what they do and I'm like damn they
definitely understand how to use
everything in their environment and make
the most out of it yeah I would look to
them to do that and I would try to see
where I would fit uh you know cuz I I
don't have that type of leadership in
that scenario that's not something that
would be great at you you could be the
guy that that passes them to leaves yeah
they tell me what to do and I will
follow those they'll be like okay well
we're gonna go do this so what I need
you to do is collect dry wood so we
could have a fire later on that's yeah
see I'm the same way man like I like
doing those things but I don't know
sometimes I spend too much time on
something that doesn't make sense
and in like too little time and it's all
half-assed yeah like so if I'm building
or whatever like I might be like [ __ ] it
and I stop it halfway and I start like
sweeping the floor yeah no I know from
watching that show like the bit the two
biggest thing is it's fire and then
shelter yeah and then after that
securing fresh water hmm so that's
that's what you should do but for sure
the first thing I'm doing is fishing I'm
stranded all this stress is making me
hungry you don't have any fire to cook
that [ __ ] you dumbass I was like nope
got it and you have to do it before it
hits nighttime yeah you need to secure
that fire well it's gonna be cold
yeah secure the fire during the day
where's the hottest so and then you just
keep the fire going until it's nighttime
I want to learn how to [ __ ] rub two
sticks and make a fire man dude I you
know you know the guy the primitive
technology guy yeah I saw his hands - it
looks callous there calestous [ __ ] yeah
and that's how he does it with his hands
because I know even for me like just
shadowboxing on cement am i both my feet
blistered like a [ __ ] you know we
have baby hands and skin like as adults
so my buddy went to Costa Rica right and
then he was telling me like there's a
tribe out there and he was looking at
their feet and then he's like all of
their feet looked like dog feet like
it's black and there's like a thick
thick layer and they run around barefoot
and it doesn't
hurt their feet and I did research about
like like primitive humans back in a day
or even today with hunter-gatherers and
when the British first met Polynesians
like they keep writing about how strong
these people are like women will will
swim across a whole entire river like
and with with a child on her back and
then they would go up and in a test like
pinched her skin and they're like they
have an extra layer what they call it an
extra layer of skin and then they have
thick like calluses and stuff like that
so I think like what humans are supposed
to do is we're supposed to build like
this layer of strength because we're not
supposed to wear shoes yeah like that's
not natural right because I always
thought like man why are humans so weak
like if we didn't have clothes and if
we'd like how would we survive or like
how did they survive back then like our
shoe of our feet so delicate we would
walk around in our like there's so many
rocks and yeah and jagged little plants
like how the [ __ ] do we survive and it
was like oh if you have that thick
callus
you could step on those [ __ ] you know
those spiky little balls and nothing
happens but in that photo I showed you
of that that indigenous like that that
should look disgusting dude if that's
what my fee has to look like to be
natural [ __ ] yeah it's definitely
because our feet are a kind of place
like if we put our hands out and we put
all our fingers together yeah that's
what our feet look like like now we're
like modern-day feet binding with your
shoes and [ __ ] yeah yeah and there's
this it's very splayed out so it's meant
to kind of be very extremely tactile and
grab onto things yeah so it's more like
RM want to spread out where the
opposable thumb is all the way out and
that's where their their uh their will
you call it the metatarsals or what do
you think they do climb trees and [ __ ]
all day I think what it is is from what
it looks like and how they were standing
when they was being gripped is that
there's there's no flat surface in the
Amazon yeah so when they're going over
rocks and trees and stuff they're
actually grabbing on to these so it's
almost like hands and develop the hand
it's very uh
primate like yeah you know which makes
me which kind of creeped me out of it
because even though we
that are were very similar to primate
yeah like what looking at those feet
made me believe it even more yeah and I
even heard or not heard I read that
primates are actually going into the
Stone Age where they're starting to use
tools they're creating tools to get
around and rather evolving dude it's so
crazy it they found out that they have a
religion now what it's like they found a
group or something and then they have
like a belief system